I'm not trying to be difficult I just
I'm kind of opposed to being put in
handcuffs like I've done something wrong
an Arkansas man says he was wrongly
detained for a clerical error with his
driver's license he says even after
explaining the situation the responding
officer put him in
cuffs if it's on this property i' would
assume it was in my access that's what
the problem is you're
assuming okay well I know for a fact I
have the paperwork it's 25 ft away from
me I can show you that real quick quick
and clear this all up all this happened
back in July in Greenbrier Arkansas
about 40 minutes north of Little Rock a
body camera captured the entire incident
on video showing an officer catch up
with Shan bresnahan in his own driveway
I'm good raon stopped you your taged
yeah I got to get him uh took care of I
just got it running last night okay it's
been sit park for bresnahan who is a
mechanic had taken out a car he'd been
fixing up for a test drive when he
pulled back into his driveway an officer
followed with you I don't I don't have
it on
me do you have a driver license I do
okay what's your name Sean bran all
right you want to step back here with me
let me get your name stuff see what's
going on with it what's been going on
with it c2700
status oh I got you early on the officer
explains it's a traffic stop hey
Sean can you go ahead and stay out here
for me bub
okay well you're I'm on a traffic stop
right now so if you would come on back
out here B just for a minute I'm still
on a traffic stop okay you understand
that you want me to step in with you and
grab your
keys okay well we can either step in and
get the keys or you can come back and
have a seat in the
car no you wasn't I could see you in the
car when I pulled up
here I don't want it to be difficult
Sean
so okay I don't want you to enter the
house without me for your safety and for
mine okay that's all I'm
asking so do you mind stepping back out
here with me so we can get this taken
care of or do we want to continue you
make it longer nearly right away the
officer says he wants to detain
bresnahan but he pushes back all right
Sean put your phone down okay I'm going
to detain you for a minute okay I get
all this figured out do
what yeah you're driving on suspended
that's why I was wanting to get in my
truck I paperwork show you it's not
suspended we'll get to it
okay I mean is there reason a reason you
put me in handcuff I'm going detain you
for a minute until I get it all figured
out out cu you're moving around you're
want to go in you want to get in the
truck you asked me to sit down I sat
down well actually you asked me to come
back out here I here and I had moved
since highp speed chases we got unruly
suspects I will kill that mother me no
do it stay in the Box I like dramatic
DUI I'mma pass everything that she
trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the ground get on the
ground law on crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
catch the action and subscribe to our
new YouTube channel
now the officer clarifies he's not
arresting bresnahan but doesn't back
down about detaining him let's Mo over
here take the reason why I'm I'm asking
you to move over here and I understand
that I'm asking you take the reason why
why I'm going to detain you while I do
my paperwork and I figure out what's
going on with your license and all
that I'm not going anywhere you got my
vehicle blocked in I don't have any
Vehicles blocked
in only keys I on me right now
is okay I'm not going
anywhere I'm asking you again Sean to
get up I'm going to detain you for a
minute let you come over here where I
can talk to you while I'm trying to deal
with you we're talking just fine right
now I don't see the are you arresting me
or are you detain detaining you at this
point okay well I'm being detained I can
do that without being in handcuff okay
I'm going to put you in handcuffs and
I'm going to detain you is there the
reason why I'm not being yes I'm just
trying to understand I'm not being
competitive I'm not no I know you're not
I'm not I'm asking you to comply with my
orders okay and you're giving me a
lawful order yes I'm giving you a lawful
order to stand up and I'm going to
detain you for a minute okay until we
figure out what's going on I'm going to
put them in front of you
okay okay while we look at the stuff
you've been over here you've been in
front of your car trying to open the
hood you're moving all the place I need
to focus on what's going on here to
decide whether you stay here or whether
you go with me bresnahan speaks up for
himself saying he's done nothing wrong
not trying to be difficult I just I'm
kind of opposed to being put in
handcuffs like I've done something
wrong you've not anything wrong I'm
detaining you to keep you over here
where I can keep an eye on I'll give you
my word I'll stay right here but I don't
want to be put
um it's not sureet time yet I can
understand the
certain the officer says bresnahan is
interfering with the investigation but
bresnahan remains relatively even
tempered but right now you're
interfering with my operation and my
investigation here because you won't
comply with what I'm asking you I'm
trying to comply but I don't feel the
need to be put in handcuffs that's being
put under arrest no it's not it's being
detained detained and that's what I told
you okay well that's detained is an
arrest no it's
not apprehension is
arrest not being able to leave your own
free will is arrest you're being
detained until I finish my investigation
that doesn't mean you're under arrest
I'm not trying to be combative I'm not
trying to Buck your Authority or
anything like that I'm just simply I
don't see why I should be handcuffed on
my own property and I haven't broken a
law you yeah what brw I broken driving
on suspend I have the paperwork to show
otherwise bresnahan tries to explain he
has paperwork to show his license is not
suspended but the officer doesn't budge
I have paperwork from the court that
shows
otherwise you have it on your person no
sir it's in my truck was it in the car
that you were driving no sir it's in my
truck okay so no different than you
being on the highway you wouldn't have
it you wouldn't have it with you that
may be true that may be true
it is different because it's here I'm
here I have it on me no you don't have
it on you if it's on this property i'
would assume it was in my access that's
what the problem is you're
assuming okay well I know for a fact I
have the paperwork it's 25 ft away from
me I can show you that real quick quick
and clear this all
up okay we might get to that point
whenever you decide to comply I'm not
trying to not comply but I was on my own
property when you pulled up behind
me mhm and now you're wanting to put me
in handcuffs you're driving down the
highway driving on suspended uh have the
paperwork to show my license is not
suspended it suspended an
error suspended an error yes sir still
bresnahan insists he's complying but the
officer says his options are limited
okay I'm going by this paperwork what I
have to deal with okay understand and
then if I can look at that then we'll
look at yours but you haven't complied
with me yet
you asked me not to move around I sat
down I hadn't moved since aside from the
calm the dog down which I asked
you mhm I've been complying this whole
time but I do not see it being necessary
be put hand I asked you I was going to
detain you and youve chose not
to so now you're interfering with
governmental operations uh not
interfering with any operation
absolutely you are I would have already
be
done if that was the case and you could
have done it with me sitting here no
problem got one of two ways brother you
can go to jail or you can be detained
for a few minutes let me figure it out
okay if you need to detain me that's
what you need to do okay I mean that's
the two options you got okay you want to
be detain for just a few minutes and
come over here and let me deal with this
and we can figure it out why do I need
to come over there I'm not trying to so
that I can ask you questions at the same
time I can't ask you questions walking
up and down the yes sir I understand
that's why I sat down that way you could
ask me questions I'm not going to yell
for my truck over here because you're
sitting at your house I want to attain
you and I'm going to put you over here
where I can talk to you okay okay
window's going to be down you're going
to be standing up body camera video
shows bresnahan clearly get frustrated
but he doesn't lose his temper even when
he's handcuffed is it all right if I
just walk over there in my own free will
we're going to put the handcuffs on
you because you being
detained I don't know why you're making
it so difficult I'll be happy to walk
truck with you and answer any questions
you have okay and I'm going detain you
in hand guys okay
let's great
okay l so don't
up all right bresnahan again attempts to
explain the error with his license
what's your license suspended for I was
suspended an error for missing Court in
Mountain
Home but my lawyer didn't about her
didn't uh inform me of the Court dat
went up there got that cleared up and
got all the charges dismissed okay
everything that I'm looking at is
showing you're suspended
still okay so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to
call
and
um I'm going check with my dispatch and
let them run it as well double
check and then we will look at the stuff
that you got going on with your
paperwork okay the officer then calls in
bresnan's name and birth date to
dispatch to get more information about
his license during this same time frame
his wife arrives to their home and
things get tense quickly driver license
with
you you want to include yourself in my
investigation so I need your ID you I
need your driver's
license here she just said she didn't
want to go inside so she's involving
herself here okay I'm not arguing need
your driver's license this is my house
understand and I wasn't doing anything
you didn't pull me over ma'am this is my
traffic stop you want to involve
yourself with the person that I'm
talking to and I asked you if you need
to go in the house and you said no
you're going to stay outside so you're
involving yourself in my investigation
so I need to identify who you involving
myself in your investigation then have
your way inside you can't tell me I have
to go inside then I
yourself one of one of the two one of
the two this is my house my property I
can stand on my property you're correct
without are you harassing me I'm not
harassing you you're involving in my
traffic style did you not talk to him
did you talk to this gentleman right
here yes he asked me for a cigarette
okay then you're involving yourself
that's my husband this is my property
all you do got to do is identify
yourself but I don't have to you can't
force me to do anything on my
proper I'm sorry I'm sorry you know my
job better than me so you tell me what I
need to do the officer threatens taking
bresnan's wife to jail too when she
accuses him of harassing her are you
talking to the person I've got in
handcuffs then you included yourself I
do not who know who he is I do not know
your
relationship okay okay do you want to
include yourself or do you not officer W
knows who we are officer wood he does
know that's fine he did not make the
traffic stop I
did okay okay but you would you me on my
property what am I harassing you about
trying to say I have to give you my
driver's license you did not pull me
over I'm not in trouble for anything so
I do not have to give you my license you
are correct you're not in trouble for
anything just yet but if you keep
interfer if you keep interfering with my
investigation you're going to go to jail
I didn't interfere with anything not
playing y's game
John there's nobody here asking I asked
her if she could go in the house okay
I'm dealing with you I do not know who
she
is that's why I want to identify her if
she wants to stay out here and talk to
you there's nothing harassing about that
when things look like they're wrapping
up the officer announces bresnan's car
will be towed show me the law that says
you can C my car right now okay here I'm
not with you here I'm going explain your
sitations to you unless you want to go
to jail and bond on them I don't but I
don't want my car to either that's
that's still on my property I don't want
you driving on I'm not going to drive it
I have other vehicle I can drive but I
apparently have driving spend license or
something so I'm not going to drive
anyway
okay but you're not taking my property
from my property okay if we were out on
the street you would have the absolute
right to tow it I still have the right
to tow it not from private property sir
okay you're driving it on City street
which is violation when you're driving
on suspended and I'm taking the vehicle
cuz you have no insurance I just sat
there and watched you drive up Wilson
Farm you drove all the way around Tyler
you come right down through here on
lender I'm taking the car you have no
insurance no driver's license and you
won't register your vehicle okay I have
no issues with registering my vehicle I
have tags that you see I just haven't
updated them okay apparently you don't
understand what we can see because you
do have a problem with driving on
suspended and you do have a problem with
registering your vehicle and I do have
it youed it very many times okay and
I've got them all dismissed as I've
shown you things again get a bit tense
when the officer asks bresnahan where he
wants his paperwork C where do you want
me to put this um give my wife
this
no I'll let you hold it cuz I don't know
that this is your wife she want to
identify herself I'm guarantee it's my
wife and officer Woody can get as well
okay well I'm not officer Woody I
understand but he is your colleague
that's fine it does not
matter I made the stop I'm trying to
cooperate with you guys but nobody wants
to cooperate you started arguing as soon
as you got out of
car okay do you want to go over this do
you want me to go over it or you just
want to have it we can go over it okay
so I cided you for owner failed to
register your vehicle for your tags
you're driving on suspended and no
liability insurance okay court date is
August tonight 1:30 p.m. if you choose
to come to that okay if you have any
questions about the citation numberers
on the back contact them anytime then
they'll be able to answer any questions
you have if you want to take that
paperwork to them they'll be the people
to show that to they can look up that
kind of stuff I can't okay they've got
other means of looking up whether your
suspension's been released or not I
can't see that okay so you can take that
city hall or you can call them and ask
them if you can bring it up there all
right and they'll let the ladies look at
it and I'll work with you man even as
argumentive as you've been if it's fixed
it's fixed and we'll make it right
okaye I guess that's fair okay any other
questions just threw a bag in the back
seat be out with Wisconsin 22
Edward William
henry2 said get a hold of Clinton sure
you
don't get picked up on that deal
somewhere yeah I'll give them a call
tomorrow find out what's going on with
that there ain't no reason to get in
trouble so you can call them and maybe
get on a payment plan or something I it
shouldn't be anything at all I didn't
even know it existed so right I don't
know
[Music]
either when bresnahan is finally taken
out of the Cuffs he tells the officer he
does not have permission to search the
vehicle the only reason you could search
my vehicle to inventory inventory is if
y'all were taking possession of it the
to company supposedly taking possession
of it and it's on my private property I
don't authorize that to search my
vehicle search my property you don't
have to um actually you do have to have
my consent to search no I don't I'm
telling the vehicle and I have to
inventory it okay you're you're not
telling me you're not telling me how to
do my job Sean either shut up or go in
the house or go to jail excuse me sir
okay you've got a couple options you can
go in the house or you can go to jail
you've been interfering with me the
whole time I've been here and I have
not arrested you yet for interfering
with governmental
operations but you're really close can
you stand here and keep your mouth shut
and let me do my job stop interfering
with me I'm asking you this last time
I'll step over here I'm asking you this
last time I apologize I'll step over
here thank you I have a question yes
ma'am is your name and badge on that
ticket because I would like it
absolutely
I'll provide
mine body camera video then shows the
officer taking a look at bresnan's
wife's license plate can I ask why
you're looking at my
vehicle go ahead
sir 043 zebra nor zebra 043 zebra nor
zebra 043 Z nor zebra returns to a 2004
Jeep white and color is to expire
October 2023 to a
la Shannon out
ofen you need my card yeah that'd be
great I'll swap with
you that's what I
figured you just want to be hard to deal
with no you didn't have a reason to run
my car are I did nothing wrong you don't
have me on a traffic spot you are
correct but you can go to jail for
interfering with my investigation I'm
not interfering with anything I'm asking
why you're running my vehicle you have
because you want to identify yourself
you keep ask you keep asking to get
involved in my investigation and he
keeps asking for you to get involved in
my investigation but you won't ID
yourself I don't have to I'm not in
trouble you're not detained okay you're
right I forgot you know the law you're
law enforcement I forgot a tow truck
arrives on the
scene we've got an interesting one so
I'm going to have to escort you to the
office to look in this vehicle he's been
very contous and uh says that I can't
tell it but you
know and it's this
mustang driving on suspended he the tag
number can you give it
one yeah we're going to get it I'm stay
it yes we're it but I got inventory let
me inventory or nothing so it's easier
just for me to escort you to the Brean
refuses to give up the keys to the car
but even so the driver starts loading it
up have you got the keys to the Mustang
I you want us to use the keys to put it
on there you want to just pull it up on
put on there at all okay I understand
that but we're P that point it is going
to be put on there I'm just trying not
to get it torn up okay
um I still don't understand what stat
law says you can take my vehicle okay
I'm not arguing with that now I'm not
trying to argue I'm asking for
verification you have to do you want us
to give us to give us the keys or do you
not I don't want to give you all my keys
now okay that's fine then we'll get out
of the way and we'll let him Jer get
[Applause]
up the responding officer gets pushy
when he sees bresnan's wife is recording
the incident
you recording this too
Lacy
awesome I am cuz then we'll subpena your
phone and it'll be gone for a
while that way we can get your recording
too make sure it matches with
ours so we canena yet we'll send it off
and get it done as the body camera
recording comes to a close bresnan's
wife asks the officer to leave her
property did you have something to say
to me I said you were the reason he the
police you're not a very good
officer done please get off my
property your your thing here is done
you do not have a reason to be on my
property you can leave I thought you
were saying something to
me you talking I am talking out loud to
this officer right here okay thank you
according to a GoFundMe page created by
bresnahan himself the entire incident
cost him thousands of dollars when his
car was sold off to a junkyard the
GoFundMe has raised nearly
$15,000 so far and just last month
bresnahan finally got his car back
reporting for long crime I'm Sierra
gaspie